Now it's time for you to meet Carol, and as I mentioned at the beginning of this course,
Carol is working in finance and her job is to design algorithms
that will optimize financial investments.
Given recent market turmoils,
her employer has asked her to come up with an algorithm
that will help them design a secure portfolio of investments.
The problem that Carol is looking at is actually quite similar to the one that Bob is looking at.
She is looking at a number of investment opportunities for her company,
for example, she could invest in precious metals such as gold, silver, or maybe even copper.
She could also invest in stocks.
So, for example, a copper mining company or in a silver and copper mining company
or she could invest in an industrial manufacturer or also in some other bank.
In order for the portfolio to be secured, she wants to spread her risk as much as possible.
She does not want to invest in things that are too similar or too closely connected.
For example, she wants to invest either in gold or in silver,
but this line here basically tells us that she does not want to invest in both at the same time,
and so she basically only wants to invest in one of those precious metal.
If she invest in copper, she probably does not want to invest in the mining company
because none of the copper price goes down so will the stock up the copper mining company.
Similar here, this is a silver and copper mining,
so either invest in this company or in those precious metals here.
If the industrial manufacturer is actually a supplier to this company here,
you probably wouldn't want to invest in both of them at the same
and let's say that the bank down here is backing the two mining company,
so you either invest in the bank or maybe also these two mining company separately
but you definitely would not want to--well, actually let's just say you also didn't want to invest
in two mining companies at the same time.
In order to spread the risk as much as possible,
Carol, of course, wants to find a portfolio that contains as many different items as possible
because then she has spread out her risk,
but at the same time, she must observe those rule.
She cannot just select all of these possibilities
but only possibilities that are not connected to each other.
The way that is very similar to Bob's problem because Bob,
when he was looking at the genes, he was looking for genes
where every gene is connected to every other gene,
and now Carol is looking for possible investments that are not connected at all to each other.
What is the largest portfolio
or how many items can Carol select at maximum so none of them are connected?
I would like you to figure that out as our next quiz
and I would like you to put your answer here in this box please.